[Music]
oh [__]
a little tonight Tuesday night check in
with you [__] up to see make sure
you're doing the right thing
tip-top Magoo if you're under 18 you
hang up right now [__] you know
what that sound is
that's the sound of mental [__]
warfare deck you understand me
in for a penny in for a [__] pound
[__]
we [__] around no more
[Music]
we find the ocean
fire [__] so beautiful night to
be alive
your uncle Joey's putting things
together before he goes out and does a
couple [__] moves you know we do it
flavor here direct on a Tuesday night
solo you know what I got sick and tired
of coming here and seeing [__] the
albums all [__] up and if you know
anything about me I love my [__]
music understand me a little first I'll
inform Aerosmith couple bonnets I got a
couple missions tonight oh [__] here you
go concept is what it's time to do a
bongo together what do you think wife
[__] get together tell me will you
knowing I tell you who to oh [__] this
is Aerosmith with the real heroin
[Music]
oh [__] you're like Joey why the [__]
you bother them in a Tuesday night I'm
gonna tell you why I'm bothering him
whatcha gonna do living like a king on
the fat of the land in a rock'n'roll
band let's do this [__] I'm
gonna show you what I did tonight
earlier I went to my daughter's swim
class
then we went we got thinner I dropped
them off I got to do a couple things
tonight you know I'm saying but I came
in I was looking at my record collection
the album collection I gotta tell you
something if the Koreans hit me with a
[__] missile I'm covered I got
everything in this [__] room and
water oxygen I got everything
albums hurricane we [__] [__] Barry I
got Pablo Escobar's pumping stash and
it's [__] off this understand me
anyway I want to show you [__]
something take a look at this [__] just
just take a look at this [__] look at
this album collection just in case
things go bad all right
we got little Aerosmith in there we got
the [__] third or fourth or whatever
out we got a little Allman Brothers
we got Benatar's [__] second out of a
classic we got the third one we got the
Black Crowes we got Black Sabbath
never-say-die paranoid the first one
essential Johnny [__] cash are you
kidding me on what the cars first out
can do one of the greatest mountains
ever [__] Cypress Hill The
Doors Strange Days la woman are you
[__] kidding me you want to commit
suicide come over here is the music dr.
Dre look he could have been present
United States on that [__] thing look
at that mug Andre right there that's a
bad [__] black man you got to
find the all-stars you got the ghetto
boys you got Rick James I'm telling you
you got Def Leppard high and dry
pyromania down through the night we got
a little Zeppelin there look at this
[__] we got Johnny we got [__] Willie
Nelson we got biggie smalls
we got Teddy double live cat scratch
ultimate Ozzy first Ozzy [__] gold
star Ozzy animals wish you were in war
the police the police
rainbow scorpions Lennox get it with the
flames on the [__] cover you [__]
savages out the flames ass on the cover
you can't even find this out of normal
we got a little [__] ride to mind the
Rolling Stones [__] made machine one
of the greatest times ever lights out
and you wait for this one and to the
[__] wu-tang ball and alphabetical
wall that's the kinda [__] uncle
Joey is you know why I don't get you got
a DD ADHD I don't give you half a
[__] [__]
we focus is here and it makes you do
whatever the [__] you need to do you
follow me
[Music]
and I still got look I still got another
[__] I gotta go steal a [__] milk
crate tonight I still got more here and
I still got more here the alum that
started all for me Richard Pryor the
[__] crazy tremendous we got [__]
somebody gave me this one Lenny Bruce
are you [__] kidding me
why are you [__] kidding me talk
you're gonna be a student of the game
you got to be a student of the [__]
game and that's it and that's that you
know me I'm not much to [__] bother
nobody
I figure like knock on the door maybe
doing [__] bong it what's wrong with
that what was the last time
oh [__] oh [__] what was the last time
somebody knocked on your door football
and said hey you busy
let's do bong it
[Music]
she broke the needle now she can't so
are you [__] nuts
if you got heroin it's time to do it
this is the first Aerosmith out when I
bought the [__] out but $10 bag H
came out a little picture of a Chinese
guys [__] oh [__] oh [__] and that's it
that's that
hang on offer you [__] I got
nothing but friendship and my [__]
heart and my balls you follow me and a
[__] bond of this [__]
oh look what I found I found this old
old blue cookie it's [__] old but
effective guinness damn it sometimes you
find some old but it's effective I found
some mushrooms in there we're gonna
sample those tomorrow that would lead
[__] these things got more mold and
[__] growing mores [__] you follow
me but anyway you know I love you
[__] always telling them we you
thought I forgot about you Thomson
gorozup great podcast [__] be real is
up great podcast you know what the [__]
you people doing I'm here giving you the
best of that [__] [__] and
ain't much but I give you my hunting my
balls I don't see nobody else do what I
[__] you follow me oh [__]
[Music]
I spit out this pie propably let's do
another partner for the spirits a silver
bounce and really really really about
tails are you [__] nuts walking your
dog
oh [__]
listen I just want let's say it again
are you [__] that you wanna hang out
with your uncle Joey but you want to
have going out of your local [__]
coffee shop talking about [__] that you
know who gives the Frenchman's [__] here
we go
well if you don't know how to do it I'll
show you how to walk the dog Aerosmith
first out a [__] monster if you don't
know now you know [__] we go
missed enough let's pick up nice no more
[__] animal I'm saying I was acting
like a [__] Donnie Molly you can't
act like a nani maoli with you [__]
it now who's this is it this is this is
what started it all and now it's making
a comeback
everybody's back why because they
shouldn't got anywhere [__] in any way
it's like all these people with your
[__] with you you [__] whatever
it is that new web page but it's the
same [__] it's the same [__] they made
you spend thousands like [__] idiots
and now they're back to it started off
the [__] piece of vinyl alright let's
put something back in here what else can
we listen to tonight yeah a little
Aerosmith you know what you know I'm in
the mood for honest to god
well I want to get down and dirty and
I'm gonna move to [__] stabbed my
mother [__] all I'm prepared to go on
stage to stab my mother [__] this is
certain band that makes me go [__]
crazy and that's the Allman Brothers
blended scared they make me go [__]
crazy because that's where you're had
one when you watch the Allman Brothers
one watch any of the shows from 71 72
and they even skin and watch them they
never got the memo they don't give a
[__] it's like me I don't give a [__] I
go up on stage to [__] do what I do
if you either you're in or you off this
[__] anyway I just want to fill you in
on that as if it was [__] important
let's listen to a little Allman Brothers
live from the film well [__] East
why not who the [__] am I not to put
them on yeah I'm saying
now we'll do a couple more bong hits you
know me doc I'm all about
the bonnet I'm all about taking care of
head the head it's the most important
thing everybody wants to be a STONER and
a vapor riser on my head I'm old school
your little Febreze for the spirits you
know I'm saying
[__] lead blast those [__] hummus
parts in here
those [__] hummus farts more like I'm
[__] you know anyway who gives a [__]
about this we're talking about family
you follow me
[Music]
you know what's dog weather in the
morning at night we take it to the hope
you follow me I think it's a hook like
Julius Erving at all [__] times see
we got a black [__] the drummer had two
drummers these guys there was 1971 73
people on there for [__] I think I
think I think the Allman something
Jacksonville Gainesville or one of those
[__] how holes do the [__] they
produce something in the water
Dickey Betts I mean they produce [__]
savages what I listen for this missus
this is it this is what you want to be
as a musician as an artist as a comedian
you got to be free right here they don't
give a [__] what you think they don't
think they don't give a [__] about kale
they don't give a [__] about that
[__] dudes dropping a missile they
all they think about is that now and
right then then and what then put them
in for their [__] art these guys are
savages I know you're young you like joy
why you turn down for the Allman
Brothers I don't want to hear that [__]
listen watch them on YouTube you know
learn something you learn the [__]
you don't learn the art the savagery and
that art is completely different there's
all different types of art the artist
savagery is doing your art imposing your
will and not giving a [__] what they
[__] think when they leave there they
may not like you but they're gonna
[__] remember you follow me and that's
the whole fun of the quarter game the
big remember [__] that's where you
go some of these houses
you [__] up their bathroom with a good
two-foot [__]
you won't get invited then I see them
but they'll remember you just a little
levity guys pumped I get so [__]
person who said bong hit let's do a
[__] money of this blue cookie normal
quality right I just wanted to check in
with you [__] to make sure
you're all right nobody's bothering you
don't saying god forbid
and don't forget San Diego this year you
know the year like I didn't get Monday
night yeah Observatory with my man we
were walking why not 15 bucks come on
down [__] Susan hi Santa and the same
thing and Sunday night I'm like the no
vote downtown and [__] anyway you put
it in Sacramento there's only Thursday
night left my vote I've been telling you
that I've been telling you that moralism
there's a nice good is one short come
out like a [__] battle anyway Joey
what's with the chitty-chat
let's do a bargain you come on sprain
for breeze with the [__]
[Music]
I don't know what to take but I smoke a
bowl and we'll figure something
beautiful nice nice and dry cooking
perennial is you
[Music]
lady [__] living with [__]
you would do that to a Chinese person
gotta run they get man I don't know what
I wanna do model in Chinese anyway I
just want checking with you
[__] you know I got you I love
you without you [__] what am i
nothing I'm just a [__] convict with
a gun that's it but I don't give a [__]
nothing but heart understand me nothing
but hunting balls I don't give a [__]
you don't take no for an answer
every no you getting closer to it yes
and that's it and that's that 22
push-ups write your goals and tell them
all to suck your dick
because at the end of the day when
you're in that [__] gas pit with that
cheap suit on and no shoes nobody gives
a [__] right or wrong and my bull Shinya
am i bullshitting you no I'm not
bullshitting go out there be a [__]
animal worry about yourself there's a
[__] he wants to be a [__]
humanitarian I worry about the people
find that black dude at 7-eleven that's
six foot seven to 80 every time I see
him I throw Nintendo at 20 why I'm gonna
get into a beef I'm gonna stick that
[__] savage on somebody someday you
followed I'm an old man with that you
know I love you I got you back
don't let nobody [__] me you don't be
scared of nothing let fear be a
motivator you follow me I'm scared of
everything it's my motivator swinging
dick and giving our [__] handshakes
and telling them all to suck your dick
because at the end of the week or you
they're getting can my mother lie big
the higher the whipping post I'll get
these [__] to mom don't forget
about me uncle Joey deep solo mission
tonight bigger the bunch